tout en parlant parfois pas
il y a
et nous revenons une fois de plus c'est déjà fini
la rue et il n'était pas là je viens de partir
avec mes enfants pour qu'ils aillent plus loin
m'attendre jusqu'à ce qu'ils doivent venir
l'eau
mais je désespère beaucoup de perle
[Musique]
il y a des voisins qui en raison d'un handicap
certaines maladies qu'ils ne peuvent pas transmettre et
les mêmes voisins s'entraident
être en mesure d'avoir ou de résoudre la journée dans
le manque d'eau
[Musique]
Salut
de la pandémie tout comme nous
nous prenions une respiration juste parce que
parce que la situation était très délicate
comme aller manger dans des restaurants qui
ce qui va se passer était la peur très
cool vrai mais nous sommes à peine
donner un groupe de pause est très pause
bref presque rien et le
suivant